what has happened to their citizens of
the reject Nation we are going to watch
the day from our buddy heavy spoilers
black panther wakanda forever original
script breakdown everything we know
joining me today John Humphrey how are
you I am excited to hear what was
originally intended how are you sir I'm
excited to learn too black panther week
is what we call it you ladies and
gentlemen leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated also make sure to
subscribe to heavy spoilers he deserves
it let's get to it
okay so we're kind of forever's original
script is something I think it's
impossible not to wander about in the
wake of the movie's release due to
Chadwick boseman's death the production
was massively changed with Ryan coogler
having to deal with the monumenter's
task of rewriting the entire thing from
the ground up because of the actor's
passing however due to interviews and
the Black Panther will conda forever
podcast we now have a fair idea of what
was going to be in it in this video
we're going to be going through
everything we know was in the original
plan and also our general thoughts about
it I do want to say really quick before
we even proceed with this video I am
still wildly impressed with the cohesive
movie they were able to pull off with
having to deal with such a left turn in
their lives in in an emotional one you
know when you're writing one of these
it's it's a really big task already as
it is and have to Pivot to this degree
and to get what they turned out that
should not be overlooked even if you
don't like the movie that much I'm like
you shouldn't Overlook the fact of the
test they had at hand so it's an
achievement a chance edwick's death
looms largely over the film with cougars
stating that he and the cast put their
loving grief into every aspect of the
movie It's felt the weekly Planet
recently touched upon what the director
experienced when finishing the first
draft buddy and we now know from the
official black panther podcast that
cougar actually sent this off to
Chadwick when discussing the script he
said I had just finished it my last
conversation with him was calling him
and asking if you wanted to read it
before I got notes from the studio that
was the last time we spoke and he passed
maybe a couple of weeks after I finished
coogler has since gone on to say that
though he never suspected Chadwick had
cancer at the time in retrospect he
could tell something was off during the
filming of the first movie he stated
that shadwick would seem tired from time
to time and that he'd need to take
breaks more often than usual in some
days we now know what Chadwick was
battling with and looking at his
performance it's actually incredible
that he got through it all with the pain
that he was in now when discussing their
last conversation coogler said he was
tired I could tell well he was tired I'd
been trying to get hold of him for a few
days I could tell something was up but
he was joking and laughing talking about
how he was planning a wedding in South
Carolina talking about the people he was
going to invite and then he said he
didn't want to read it because he didn't
want to get in the way of whatever notes
the studio might have so he was like
it's better if I read it later but I
found out later that he was too tired to
read anything
to find this out and it's clear that he
influenced how they handled t'challa's
passing due to him fighting his disease
in secret that's pretty freaking crazy
you know reflecting on that like when
you're filming one of these movies it's
already such a massive toll on the body
there's a lot of times it's like it's 16
18 hour days top of that too he's the
lead actor who has to stay in like Peak
Physical shape for this kind of
character so naturally like people will
be tired naturally these things that
he's saying he was having issues with or
that people observed they're going to
come come up but you can just imagine
the extremity and the strain it must
have taken on his body and the fact that
he didn't even like talk about it with
people like it was his choice to not
talk about it it's just wild oh yeah it
was the amazing amount of Grace to then
be like hey I am not going to tell you
I'm not going to worry you but also I'm
gonna meet myself at my ability and I
can't read this but I'm not gonna make
it about me I'm just gonna make it about
encouraging you to take that script and
keep on moving with it it's crazy to
think that he would have passed just
after that because yeah especially
planning a wedding on top of it not
cluing anybody into what was about to
happen it makes you Ponder like did he
choose not to read it because he thought
he would actually pass or was it just
because of how he was solely just
feeling at the time we'll never know CBR
recently reported that Chadwick did in
fact get the chance to read it though
and that Leticia write her through the
grapevine that the actor had been making
fun of how long it was
it was over 300 Pages which would make
it one of the longest MC movies ever
this carries people already thought it
was long yeah wakanda forever forever
forever interestingly though we now know
that the original version also dealt
with the themes of grief too in an
interview with inverse coogler laid out
the entire plan and the first thing he
talked about was the grief that the
movie tackled with however this was
t'challa dealing with his own grief of
the snap and the time that was lost when
Thanos snapped away half of all life in
the universe t'challa was one of the
Unlucky ones that were taken and this
would have left the throne empty for
five years coogler said that the movie
was gonna address this directly and that
its tone would be similar to what we got
in the final release we're going over
this Ryan said the character was going
to be grieving the loss of time you know
coming back after being gone for five
years as a man with so much
responsibility to many coming back after
a forced five years away that's what the
film was tackling he was grieving time
he couldn't get back grief was a big
part of it coogler stated that Shiri was
snapped away too and that they would
both return with this feeling of loss
yeah that would have been a very very
fascinating tale to tell especially
because it doesn't really feel like the
MCU has been really dealing with a story
that that has that when that is such a
big thing of loss and something to
grieve you know I think of those stories
of people who do wake up out of like a
coma or something after so many years
and the things they missed out on or
being away in prison or something like
that you know like you're missing out on
life watching have so many things change
and developed and what you might have
been able to do differently if you had
been around like there are so many
interesting concepts of grief one could
have done if black panther wakanda
forever was always meant to be the the
end of phase four exploring that as the
topic for your final film of phase four
would have made the whole package feel
that much more complete and would have
made it even more have it make more
sense why it would be the end of phase
four that's a really good point because
yeah we've seen it in these little fits
and bursts that are always so striking
but the more films you get away even if
the timeline is still pretty close it
feels like the further you get away from
that event so that would have been a
beautiful way to thematically Cap all of
this phase but at the same time it
doesn't seem like it would be anywhere
near as impactful as what this was yeah
I'd try I'd trade the current
circumstances back of course we haven't
really dealt with what happened in those
five years it's been minor moments like
the Ronin plot in the Disney plus
Hawkeye show but beyond that it's
something we know very little about it's
meant to be a completely depressing time
too with Haywood and one division saying
they had to do dark things in order to
survive this ended up making him work to
bring Vision back to life so that planet
Earth had its own protector coogler said
that wakanda forever would tackle this
idea too and then element of the final
film was laced throughout this early
draft in that we watches France attempts
to steal vibranium from the wakandans
that one of their research Labs the
original script had elements of this as
well were the fact that t'challa was
gone for five years causing big issues
Kingdom didn't have a black panther to
protected several government entities
had tried to intrude an attack in order
to gain the precious material for
themselves killmonger destroyed all of
the Sacred herbs and because of this
they couldn't pass the mantle onto
anyone else the nation had no protector
and this put even more guilt onto the
shoulders of t'challa he returned to
find wakandra in the midst of a cold war
with the UN desperate to gain vibranium
the film of course ended with t'challa
opening up wakanda to the world and he
would have to deal with the fact that
they had betrayed him though Michael B
Jordan's return Isn't mentioned in any
of the interviews I think this is
because of spoilers that it could bring
to people going to see the film damn you
know that would have been a cool ass
movie
[Music]
the way it's being laid out here I'm
going that really would have been a
great movie as someone struggling to
it's like it's not their fault and
that's such a relatable guilt feeling I
think it's not your fault of why you're
you you were absent it's it's not your
fault for this situation yet the burden
of responsibility and the pain of guilt
still really weighs heavy you know
watching as one of the most powerful
Nations though arguably the most
powerful nation in the world is now now
weakened because of your absence and and
is lacking guidance and having to regain
all that I still feel like the wakanda
forever subtitle would have been fitting
and I can still see all the threads now
from the film that we actually did get
of how you they would rework it for the
film that we did ultimately get that but
I could see how it could have been part
of the original story now too because
that would have been a it would have
been a very compelling commentary to
have done because he would have returned
to like a more temporary version of the
circumstances that we do see here and
two to build upon the first movie I feel
like a lot of people said like it's a
great Ensemble and Chadwick is great but
I think that would have taken t'challa
as a character even more introspective
even even more personal and dived even
further into just Chadwick's incredible
range as an actor I think that he would
have appeared in the film in some form
or another he wanted to take the fight
of the world and make wukon known
through the use of force t'challa on the
other hand wanted it to be peaceful and
I can't help but think seeing hashtag
killmonger was right might make him
question his own leadership abilities
the Chola was very much forced into
being King by the sudden death of his
father and though he beat him Baku for
the throne his Reign had been marked by
a lot of turmoil we of course had killed
Monger usurping him and then Thanos
attacking wakande so it's a lot to deal
with and him failing to protect his
Nation would be another big thing that I
think would have added to the guild
definitely the villain of the movie it
was always gonna be no more with coogler
stating that he was always the
antagonist Black Panther and Amor have
fought several times in the comics
before with both Atlantis and wakanda
going to war with each other in the
comics no more and t'challa's rivalry
was first introduced in the 1970s but
when we look at the timeline of the
Marvel Universe they fought long before
that the first battle happened during
World War II and over the decades
they've had an uneasy Alliance that's
constantly constantly broken there's
been several tense exchanges with him
and pretty much every time they talk
there's a chance things could kick off
Black Panther and Amora some of the only
Marvel characters that are actually
rulers and it's not like when Iron Man
back somewhere because he isn't the
leader of a country
and therefore Every Act is seen as
something that can destabilize the peace
on the political landscape interestingly
sure you know more fought each other
during Civil War II which may provide a
basis for the final cut the tidal wave
scene was there too with us being a
major attack that no more launched
because of this I'm guessing that
ramundo died in the original version of
the script without starting a streak of
Vengeance within the king t'challa the
final release ends with Shiri realizing
that vengeance is consuming her and this
is a line that calls back to t'challa
saying it in Civil War yeah you know I
think one of the things that does enough
just a pure fan level that does bum me
out is it's like how
it's definitely not a one-on-one
comparison but how uh Iron Man's arch
nemesis is the Mandarin and we didn't
really get to see that here it was
setting it up for t'challa to fight his
arch nemesis we didn't see it at all you
know yeah I wish there was that part was
like down the road one day imagine these
Marvel movies one day get remade you
know sure and I think Winston Duke was
even talking about that recently
there'll be a time in the future we do
get to see the t'challa versus Neymar
something that I'm like oh yeah that
would have been great to see just them
two fighting each other yeah and those
two actors because you could go well in
15 years you know a little t'challa can
take him yeah but it's not the same
thing for this timeline yeah I think
that a similar Motif might have happened
once more with t'challa again realizing
that this will just start a cycle of
violence mbaku warns of wakanda and
talukan devolving into nations of
Eternal War which I think may have been
a theme that was apparent in the
original version I do think that by the
sounds of it the basic backbone of the
film would have been the same with the
Chala questioning his leadership which
does get replaced by shuri questioning
her own skills and abilities to hear the
fact that she couldn't make a herb is
her basically thinking that she led to
his death and no that's not the case I
think this Motif would have mirrored the
failure t'challa felt about his own
kingdom unfortunately we'll never know
what the original script would have
played out like due to the death of
Chadwick Boseman but I personally think
that the final result perfectly handles
his passing grief is a central theme to
it it drives the characters and their
actions in the movie that's how much
pepper is gone his presence is felt
throughout and we of course end knowing
that his legacy carries on either way
there's lots to unpack from this and
obviously let me know your thoughts on
the script details and your general
thoughts on the movie too thank you Paul
for putting that together uh yeah that
was really uh insightful to know I
didn't know most of that that's pretty
crazy yeah that would have been an
interesting ass film not gonna lie that
would that would have been great and I
wish we lived in the timeline where we
did get that movie timeline that we do
live on I think we we got the best case
scenario of a film
um agreed which I know some people don't
agree with him but where we stand ladies
and gentlemen follow Paul leave a like
subscribe click that Bell last but not
least let's end this video off
[ __ ]
you've been a patron of ours for 26
whole months that is a loyal super sexy
reject right there two years you've been
doing this and I want to say thank you
you've gifted us with other things
before more than just your generous
pledge you've gifted us with actual
awesome items that we have definitely
frequently used and then on top of that
too if this was just a great energy and
personality to share with us so thank
you fox for being part of our lives for
so long yeah and um I pre we genuinely
appreciate the support and uh it feels
unconditional so thank you for being you
and I hope you have a great holiday
season because you've earned it you've
earned it you deserve it for being
loyalty pays off and now you go and reap
those benefits Chill on the beach or
something like that no refunds but I
love you
[Music]